[Music]
marissa is in bend oregon hi marissa how
can ken and i help
hi thank you for taking my call
my husband and i we are
really frustrated living in oregon right
now and so
uh we are wanting to move somewhere that
um to a state that is more in line with
our values and what we want for the
future for our children
and we are in the middle of baby steps
three and four
so just trying to you know your
advertisement about a game plan so just
trying to figure out what would be the
best game plan to
plan a move like this something we had
not planned on doing um at all we both
were born and raised in oregon but it's
just it's just too much we just
it's so heartbreaking the place you were
born the place you love the place you
were raised doesn't feel like home
anymore no not at all yeah so what is
that what are the key things that are
driving you out of there
um
so a lot of it is just you know the
unrelenting mandates
i work for state government my husband
works for
indian tribe here
so it just is you know one thing after
another our kids are just being
bombarded by
you know liberal anti-christian
views um when they're in school we
actually live in more of a rural area so
we don't have any other schooling
options for them
so those are the two big things a lot of
the politics just you know the constant
socialist ideas that are being passed
down in oregon
so i mean all of it
well the reason i ask is not to stir up
trouble but i think it is good for
elected officials to hear
why their citizens are leaving right um
and it's happening in california new
york and mass
it's happening in oregon and washington
state
it's happening around some of the major
cities where the city has lost control
they've lost control of their cities
and um and and people are they're not
you know people who are the producers in
our culture who are the peop the artists
who make the art the business people who
run the businesses the administrators
who administrate the good moms and dads
who do show up at the pta meetings uh
they've lost their tolerance for this
stuff and um we're seeing one of the
biggest migrations in the history of the
united states right now is since the
time that this country was actually
settled
it's it's pretty bizarre so that's why i
bring it up it's kind of a philosophical
thing but worth talking about yeah
marissa i'm curious if you could tell
dave and i uh what's driving the
destination the most is it the where or
is it the what what you guys will need
to do uh from a professional standpoint
just curious
well i i actually work in a prison here
in oregon so you know my career field
i'm not necessarily anticipating being
able to stay in
but my husband is a farmer
he actually farms for
like i said a native american tribe for
their tribal government so he's very
much i mean he has an ag degree from
texas so that's kind of why we're
looking at texas he's um you know
familiar with texas really liked going
to school there
so he his degree is in ag economics so
he can run
any part of a farm from the business end
to the manual end so
we're just right now we're focusing on
getting him a job and where where would
that be what would that look like
especially in the midwest i mean even
just uh job opportunities for him in
oregon the farming community where
they're out of water like
you know so
his his opportunities
regardless of the politics are becoming
few and far between so
so that's another another thing that's
driving our desire to move is career
opportunities as well what do you what
do you do tactically just to function in
the prison system what kind of a job is
it administrative in nature
what do you do
right now i run a life skills program so
transitioning work so i can do that kind
of stuff in a variety of settings
um and i also have uh experience in
administration so okay great so i just
wanted a little bit more marketable yeah
you know working for a different type of
environment i think your your career
field might be can correct me if i'm
wrong more defined by what you do rather
than where i think that's been doing it
so i really wouldn't i mean i think it's
i've been running a life skills program
i've been in administration oh by the
way happened to be yes in a prison
system yeah i agree so once you guys get
where the the right gig is for the hubs
this is a wonderful wonderful job market
right now and you're going to be very
very attractive to a lot of different
people so i just wanted to ask about
that so i think dave at this point it's
you know okay we got to figure out the
place we've got a wonderful relocation
guide that i do want to make sure kelly
gives them uh at the end of this call we
had a ramsey relocation guide it's free
it really helps you walk through a
checklist of everything from real estate
professional uh schools packing
everything you can imagine because part
of the thing that freaks people out
about a move is not having a plan you
know it's just like what do i think of
there's a million things and certainly
when you're uprooting from one state and
moving cross-country that's terrifying
but we do have a great tool we want to
give her that'll help i don't even know
that you didn't know that yeah i talked
about on the ken coleman show we have a
lot of people changing jobs
and so yeah
i guess i don't know these things i've
given away yeah it's a checklist so it
helps you come up with a plan marissa we
have this great reload no okay anyway
the um
the thing that comes to mind for me is i
i always have to put stuff like this how
do you eat an elephant a bite at a time
you said how do you lay out a game plan
i always have to put stuff that's this
big a task in order
uh almost like a flow chart until this
happens i can't go to the next thing
and the first thing for you guys is to
land careers right
you can't go on a wing in a prayer and
hope somebody hires you
so when you if you both had jobs making
more or
equal to what you're making now in a new
market now moving starts to be
mathematically fairly easy
and that's another thing that's been
overwhelming is
you know
just the cost of living and our salaries
here are
quite a bit more than when i look at
like texas oklahoma kind of midwest
but i also know that we're going to be
able to buy a house that's probably half
the price of our house here you know so
just trying to keep things those things
in perspective too but when you look at
you can now you can make you can land
you can land the career
with a track uh uh you know land the
position both of you
then in whatever city and you say okay
that's where we're going then you can
start unraveling the stuff on your end
and making the leap but making the leap
until you have the income waiting on you
at the new place
is um that's really dangerous and so
that would be my biggest and first thing
i would do if i were in your shoes is to
you know jump on king coleman's site use
all of his tools to land that job you
love and this may be a time to
transition into a different segment of
your career field that gives you more
meaning yeah as well but uh landon land
that first and then you can talk about
selling your house buying a house you
can talk about moving you can talk about
uh actually loading up the truck and
heading to beverly hills it is swimming
pools and movie stars texas tea
this
is the ramsey show